لنبدأ بمجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة، فقد
أصدر هذا القرار الذي يدعو إلى
المزيد من المساعدات ولكن ليس وقف إطلاق النار،
ما الذي فعلته بهذا التصويت بالنظر إلى
ما كنت تراه كل يوم في
غزة، شكرًا مايكل، نحن بالتأكيد بحاجة إلى
المزيد من المساعدات، نحتاج إلى المزيد من المساعدات حتى تأتي
المعبر أه المعبرين
المفتوحين أه لكننا نحتاج أيضًا إلى أن نكون قادرين على
الوصول لإيصال المساعدات إلى
الميل الأخير للأشخاص الذين هم في أمس الحاجة إليها
وهناك قيود خطيرة على الوصول
أم أنه لا يوجد
شاحنات كافية  القادمين عبر الحدود
ليس هناك ما يكفي أه من الشاحنات تتحرك عبر
غزة بسبب ظروف
الطريق بسبب نقاط التفتيش بسبب
أه العمليات
لتحركات فض الاشتباك لذلك نحن غير قادرين على
إيصال ما نحتاج إليه  إلى
الأشخاص الذين هم في أمس الحاجة إليها،
نعم، هذا هو الشيء الذي يعني الحصول على المساعدات هو
شيء، وتوزيعها في مكان
مثل غزة مع ما يحدث هو شيء
آخر تمامًا. أنا أتساءل أنك تعلم أنني
سمعت الكثير عما كنت تفعله
تقول وما كنت تراه
وتفعله، هل تعتقد أن الكثير من العالم
قد أصبح غير مدرك للمشاهد خارج
غزة عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالسكان المدنيين؟ الوفيات والإصابات المذهلة
تحصد أرواح الجوع والمعاناة، هل تعتقد أن هذا هو
الحجم؟  كل هذا
مفهوم تمامًا حتى خارج القطاع، أعني هل
أصبح الفلسطينيون
مجردين من إنسانيتهم، وآمل أن لا آمل أن
يفهم الناس أن هؤلاء أشخاص،
هؤلاء مدنيون، أطفال ونساء،
للأسف يفقدون كرامتهم
في الوقت الحقيقي، نحن نشهد ذلك
يحدث أننا نرى الناس يبكون من
أجل الطعام ويصرخون من أجل الماء، إنهم
يائسون، وآمل ألا
يصبح العالم مخدرًا به لأنه لا
يزال يحدث كل يوم،
نحن اليوم  عيد الميلاد ونحن نراكم
تعرفون النساء والأطفال رأيت
عائلة مع طفل صغير أم
طفل حافي القدمين يركض حافي القدمين في
الطريق تحت النار محاولاً الهروب، آمل
ألا نصبح مخدرين تجاه ما نحتاج إليه،
ولهذا السبب نحتاج إلى  وقف إطلاق النار نحتاج
إلى فهم مستوى
المعاناة الإنسانية وإيقافها نعم
حجمها يفوق الخيال أعني بما
يزيد عن 60 عامًا قد
يقترب من 70٪ الآن من الوحدات السكنية أه
مدمرة أو متضررة أه أين الناس
أعيش أين سيعيشون
خلال
أشهر الشتاء أعني مايكل خارج
النافذة بجواري مباشرةً هناك الآلاف من
الأشخاص يعيشون في ملاجئ مؤقتة أم
هنا في رافا كل رصيف مغطى
بالملاجئ أه في كل مكان تذهب إليه
ترى الناس يتنقلون  عندما كنت في
مدينة غزة قبل بضعة أيام كنت ترى
الأطفال والعائلات يمشون
بأعلام بيضاء في نهاية العصا أثناء
التنقل في محاولة للعثور على مكان آمن للبقاء فيه،
لذلك هناك عدد أقل وأقل من الأماكن التي
توجد بها العديد من المباني.  لقد تم تدمير المزيد
والمزيد من الأراضي وأصبحت غير آمنة
والناس في حالة تنقل مستمر
بما في ذلك زملائي الذين اضطروا إلى
التحرك ثلاث مرات وأربع وخمس مرات أه لمواصلة
البحث عن الأمان، والجو
يزداد برودة، والمطر يزداد هنا،
والعديد من الأشخاص بما في ذلك هؤلاء
الأشخاص  الذين يبعدون عني 50 متراً
ينامون تحت البلاستيك،
الوضع الحالي لا يصدق